はいどぉぉもぉぉぉ！！（全力）
シー、シー！
バカ、また俺 壁ドン来るんだから…（小声）
[はじめ]あっはい、ごめんなさい…
[はじめ]これ投げていいですか？
[トミック]ダメだ…
[トミック]これはさすがにダメ
はい、久しぶりの、"アゴシャベル"の家ですっ！
[トミック]しばくよ…？（殺意）
[はじめ]ははぁっ…（怯え）
今日はですね、こちら！
ブレスケアです。
トミックさんへんな匂i...
いや、何でもないです
え、正直言って？マジで匂う俺？
(本気で心配するトミック)
匂わないですｗｗ
[トミック] ブレスカァー
[はじめ]no~nnno~
[はじめ]ブレスケーア
[トミック] no,no..
[トミック]フィリスクァ
[はじめ]no~nnno~
[はじめ] ブゥリスキ …
[２人]ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
息の匂いをきれいにする、
ブレスケアというものがあります。
詰め替え用で、100粒入っております。
一袋、100粒入っているんですけど
うわ、結構しんどいっすよ
[トミック]いや行けるってこれは
というわけで [手拍子] えーっと、
10袋準備したので、合計1,000粒になります。
[トミック] ｳﾝ
[はじめ]今日はね、こちらの、
天才ハジメんと、
妖怪"アゴシャベル"の２人で、
1,000粒食っていこうと思います。
[はじめ] ｳｯ…
(妖怪"アゴシャベル"の攻撃)
（拍手）
[はじめ]だしてぇ...(´・ω・`)
なんか、いくらの品種改良の みたいですね
[トミック]（笑い）
[トミック]あー、
なんかもう凄いコレ。
ビーズだ。
[アゴシャベル] ﾁｯ...
(些細なことにビビる天才ハジメん)
[トミック]（見せなくても）いいよそれ...
[はじめ]ﾀﾞﾝﾀﾞﾀﾞｰn…
[はじめ]あああああぁぁぁぁ!（絶叫）
[トミック]おい！おい！ふざけんな！！
[はじめ]ぇっ拾って拾って…
[はじめ] ⇧
[トミック]ダメ…ああぁぁぃダｍ（ｒｙ
意外とでもさぁ...
いやっ...
待てよ...
ただブレスケアをするだけじゃ、楽しくないだろ...
何のために持ってきたんだ？（にんまり）
[はじめ]なんでそんな楽しそうなんすかｗｗｗ
[トミック]たのしいよぉ♪
[はじめ]何か久しぶりにやりましたもんね
丼より少なめなので
ちゃんと息がきれいになるかという実験のために
今日は、トミックさんの主食、"ニンニク"を…
[トミック]主食じゃねえよｗｗｗ
[はじめ]食べてｗｗいきたいｗｗとｗ思いますｗｗｗ
はいっ
ｸｻｯ!
こんな臭いんｯｽかニンニクって
[はじめ]ｶﾞｯ
[はじめ]ｶﾞﾌｯ
明日みんなに臭いっｔ…
あっ！？辛くないっすか！？
[トミック]…からいよ？
[はじめ]辛っ!
[トミック]あっ辛いね...
[トミック]ｵｲ!
[トミック]あかんよ…
[はじめ]ｴｪｱｯ…ｸｯ…
[はじめ]ﾔﾊﾞｲ、ﾔﾊﾞｲ…
待って、舌痛い
（お茶を注ぎ入れ始める妖怪）
（それを遮るかのごとく
はじめのコップにお茶の口を近づける はじめ）
ｗｗｗ、お前しばくよｗ
[はじめ] ｗｗｗ
ちょ、もう口の中はトミックさんのわけで
ニンニクに犯されてたら、多分臭いです
トミックさん、「はぁ～」ってして？
（トミックさんの口の中は、
もう既に くさやレベル（予想））
うぅうぇゎあぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁっっ！！
（トミックさんの口の中は、
もう既に くさやレベル（予想））
ﾊﾞｼｯ
（トミックさんの口の中は、
もう既に くさやレベル（予想））
はい、というわけでさっそく、
1,000粒食っていきましょう！
[トミック] ﾍｲ
（拍手）
いぇええいっっ！！！（必死の盛り上がり）
[トミック]あっ シー！
（カット音）
[はじめ]まって、一粒食って様子を見てみたい…
（⇧ 破裂音は割りと大きめ）
[はじめ]硬っ…
[トミック]ｗｗ
ぁぁ、そういう感じね
なんか、キシリトールのガムを、圧縮した感じ
辛っ…
（⇧ 大きめな破裂音）
ああっ…(TдT)
…歯、折れる。
[はじめ]うわっ、うわっ
（⇧ [トミック]大きめな破裂音を鳴らしまくる）
（⇧ [トミック]大きめな破裂音を鳴らし続ける）
ｳｳｩｩｴｴｪｪｪｯｯ!
[はじめ]ちょっ…ｗｗ
汚い、トロール！(自分も汚い)
地球人はそんなことしちゃダメなのっ
わかる？ｗｗ
（一切口が開かなくなる２人。）
うわっ耳痛い…耳痛い 耳痛い 耳痛い…
（[はじめ]鼻をかむ）
（[トミック]鼻をかむ）
トミックさん、魚とか飼ってないですか？
飼ってないよ...
魚飼ったらこれ あの～、下の水槽の石に
敷いてあげてください。
[トミック]ｗｗｗｗ
綺麗な水槽が出来上がりですよｗｗ
余裕ですよ、こんなん…（今更なフラグ構築）
[はじめ]ｺﾞｯ…!
(数粒のブレスケアが床に こぼれ落ちる)
（口いっぱいに広がったブレスケアが、
徐々にはじめの身体を蝕んでいく）
[はじめ]ｶﾞｯ…!
（口いっぱいに広がったブレスケアが、
徐々にはじめの身体を蝕んでいく）
（ふ た り の し ず か な じ か ん）
[トミック] フッフッフッフッフｗｗｗｗ
(そして…)
（ふ た り の し ず か な じ か ん）
[トミック]ｗｗｗｗ
（せーのっ…）
（ふ た り の し ず か な じ か ん）
[トミック]どうする...？（小声）
[トミック]多分ね、息は完全に綺麗になったと
思うんだけどさぁ...
（はじめ、言う気力もなく 静かに頷く）
（そしてトミックは首を鳴らす）
終わりますか...（ブレスケアで無気力）
[トミック]終わらせる？
[はじめ]大事なのは...
息がきれいになること…（そりゃそうだ）
[トミック]ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
[はじめ]mission clear!!
[トミック]www...
だってそうじゃないｯｽか。
[トミック]まぁね
[はじめ]息綺麗になればいいんですよ。
皆さん、このたびは本当に、すいませんでした！
すいませんでした!
お前ｗもう一回やれよｗ
（字幕：きまぐれシュワー）
（字幕を御覧の皆様、
最後までご視聴ありがとうございました。
この後すぐ、お知らせがございます。）
一つお知らせがございます
劇団スカッシュさんの短編ドラマに、
僕が出ることになりました。⇨
それで、えーとそのドラマで僕がしゃべるセリフを
ですね、皆さんのコメントで決めます。
劇団スカッシュさんのこの動画のコメント欄に、僕に、ドラマで言ってほしいコメントを、書いてください
皆さんが書いたコメントで、
僕のドラマのセリフが決まります。
ぜひ、
かっこいいコメント、待ってます(終了)